sometimes I just like to think of the
ICT 3cs community as a lift climbing up
a building where the first floor is
terrible and the top floor will use the
heavens and as the Oct 3 community is
slowly moving upwards floor by floor but
dropping off passengers as it goes
getting smaller all the time while those
in a get better and better and those in
the bottom trying to join it or have any
increasingly high time getting in and
this lift has been ignored for ten years
and suddenly it's caught up in a storm
of games thrown at it theme parks to do
park attacks roller coaster tycoon for
Mobile coaster park tycoon and ICT world
and I think it's no wonder why the
community is so upset about ICT world it
appears to be numerous floors down from
where the lift is now and this goes for
those who only played the original ICT a
long time ago too as far as I can say
I've seen some good screenshots mediocre
blog posts and a bad trailer which have
not even going to make an analysis of
because everyone can see what's wrong
with it just look at those fountains
those toothpick supports that frame
rates but I'm still hopeful and I'll
probably still buy the game but the
overall sense of negativity repels me
more than the game itself almost
everyone everywhere is extremely
negative about the game because if the
trailer that just came out or which we
don't even know whether it's an
up-to-date representation of the actual
gameplay there are actually rumors that
it's much older and I feel bad for the
developers of yct world who are likely
the victim of poor marketing terrible
communication but I think the real issue
here is that what carries a game in my
opinion is the feelings that it brings
with it and the community to the
friendly and innovative community has
kept ITT 3 alive all these years and the
first two installments are still popular
due to nostalgia and their overall
feelgood factor ICT world seems to lag
behind in the latter and who knows
whether the community will be able to
lift it like it happened with ICT 3 but
it depends on the community to not be
such a manifestation of butter and yeah
I understand that people on mad but I
don't think for mining every corner of
the internet with hate is going to help
and hey at least the game does come with
unlimited cotton candy but to be honest
the only game that I'm really excited
for now is parka texts
I always put off at first by their
graphics and a seemingly unoriginal
gameplay but I'm hooked right now due to
the small teams involvement they're
active on the forums taking suggestions
hosting blogs of the progress weekly and
actually live-streaming and making
videos of the two and most of all they
seem to enjoy making the game and I
can't tell whether I like playing it but
it's already been fun to see the
development of it and I know this is
just wishful thinking but I think that
this is how games should be and
rollercoaster tycoon world being the
marketing trainwreck than it is right
now should definitely look at this and
learn how community interaction actually
works oh and next time you guys complain
that rollercoaster tycoon world looks
bad and then I need to make analysis
videos of the trailers and all that I'll
prepare a roller coaster tycoon 3ds
let's play just for you